veamos quién llega el peso del impuesto
en diferentes situaciones en esta
ocasión nos enfocaremos en la insulina
la insulina es necesaria para los
diabéticos para mantener el control de
su nivel de azúcar así que pueden
imaginarse que ellos necesitan la
insulina para sobrevivir por lo que
existe un beneficio marginal infinito
para ellos ya que no importa a qué
precio estén ellos están dispuestos a
comprar la insulina que necesitan para
vivir digamos que si un doctor dice que
un diabético necesita tres mil dosis por
año para sobrevivir las personas van a
comprar esas unidades no importa cual
sea el precio de la insulina ellos están
dispuestos a comprarlas para sobrevivir
por ejemplo si el precio de la insulina
fuera de un dólar por dosis y los
doctores en esta ciudad dijeran que
colectivamente todos los diabéticos
necesitan tres mil dosis al año para
sobrevivir ellos tomarán estas 3.000
dosis al año si el precio fuera de 80
dólares por dosis la gente seguiría
comprando estas 3.000 dosis por año y
dentro de un rango de precios razonables
no habrá cambio en la cantidad que se
demanda así que en este caso y en un
rango de precios razonable la curva de
demanda para la insulina es vertical
obviamente si el precio subiera a 90
millones de dólares la dosis pues ahí si
la gente ya no la compraría ya no podría
comprarla y entonces la curva ya no
sería vertical pero al menos dentro de
un rango de precio razonable esta curva
de demanda va a ser vertical así que
esto de quieren nuestra curva de demanda
y ustedes pueden recordar de cuando
hablamos de la elasticidad esta es una
demanda inelástica es perfectamente
inelástica ustedes pueden pensar en esto
como si fuera un ladrillo un ladrillo es
perfectamente inelástico no importa
cuánto lo empuje no lo estiren o traten
de estirarlo nunca va a cambiar su forma
al menos con el nivel de fuerza de una
persona normal así pues el ladrillo es
opuesto a un resorte un resorte es muy
elástico en cambio el ladrillo no se va
a deformar de esta manera así que
recordemos la definición de elasticidad
como la hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
elasticidad es el porcentaje del cambio
en la cantidad entre el porcentaje del
cambio en el precio
y aquí no importa que tanto estemos
cambiando el precio al menos dentro de
este rango las personas van a seguir
demandando 3000 dosis por año así que
permítanme dibujar la curva de la oferta
la curva de la oferta luce así así que
esta es la oferta si aquí no tuviéramos
impuestos ni regulaciones con base en la
forma en la que lo he dibujado aquí el
precio de equilibrio caería en el 75 y
de hecho investigue un poco antes de
hacer este vídeo y justamente este es el
precio de la dosis de insulina y está en
el punto de equilibrio porque esta es
exactamente la cantidad que necesitan
las personas 3.000 dosis por año y aquí
hay algo bastante interesante para
reflexionar una situación en donde
tenemos una demanda perfectamente
inelástica cuál va a ser el excedente
del consumidor y el excedente del
productor el excedente del productor
trata de que tanto más dinero van a
obtener en relación al costo de
oportunidad o al costo marginal
incremental y como en muchas ocasiones
lo hemos hecho ese es el excedente del
productor
área en la que tenemos el precio de
equilibrio y nuestra curva de oferta así
que este es el excedente del productor
pero ese nuestro excedente del
consumidor donde las cosas se ponen
interesantes el excedente del consumidor
es que tanto más obtiene las personas
del beneficio marginal comparado con lo
que pagan y tradicionalmente habíamos
dicho que era el área debajo de la curva
de demanda y el precio pero de pronto
esta área es infinita una forma de verlo
es que esas personas diabéticas van a
obtener casi un beneficio marginal
infinito de esta insulina ya que les
permite tener una vida saludable
simplemente les permite permanecer vivos
para ellos
esencialmente esto no tiene precio muy
interesante esta idea de tener casi un
excedente del consumidor infinito en
este caso significa que este beneficio
es tan grande porque les permite
mantenerse vivos y si esto fuera un
poquito más elástico imaginando un
escenario del mundo real en el que
quizás esto sea un poquito más caro y
hayan diabéticos que traten de bajar la
dosis que necesitan
esta curva podría tener una pequeña
elasticidad
así que se pueden imaginar que si esto
lo extiendo hacia arriba a un precio de
20 millones de dólares y ahí lograr
tener un límite para el área del
excedente del consumidor pero sin duda
sería un enorme excedente del consumidor
el que tendríamos aquí haciendo esto a
un lado veamos qué sucede cuando algún
político desorientado se le ocurre poner
impuesto a la insulina que de hecho es
una idea muy mala y en la que yo no
estoy a favor en lo absoluto pero veamos
quién se llevaría la carga aquí y yo
creo que ustedes se imaginan quién va a
hacer pero de todas maneras analicemos
esto con las herramientas que tenemos y
veámoslo con esta curva de demanda
perfectamente inelástica digamos que se
aprueba un impuesto de 10 dólares por
dosis y aquí en lugar de un porcentaje
lo estoy determinando como una cantidad
fija para poder percibir esto como un
desplazamiento fijo en el precio para
los productores esto es lo que necesitan
tener para producir 3.000 dosis ellos
necesitan 75 dólares por cada 2
si queremos que produzcan una primera
dosis van a necesitar 60 dólares así que
lo que los productores necesitan más el
impuesto vamos a dibujarlo como otra
curva así que si para esta primera dosis
los productores necesitan 60 ahora con
el impuesto van a necesitar 70 ya que le
agregamos el impuesto para mi dosis si
teníamos esto le agregamos el impuesto y
se va a desplazar hasta acá para 3000
dosis se necesitaban 75 dólares más el
impuesto pues ahora va a estar en 85
dólares
así que obtenemos esta nueva curva de
oferta lo pueden ver como el precio
desde el punto de vista del consumidor o
pueden verla como la curva de la oferta
más impuestos así que aquí lo escribimos
la oferta más impuestos y ahora está en
donde va a interceptar nuestra curva de
demanda perfectamente inelástica pues se
pueden imaginar que las personas a pesar
de que se ha aumentado el precio de la
insulina las personas de todas maneras
necesitan conseguir esta misma cantidad
de dosis al año así que se intersecta en
esta misma cantidad pero se tiene un
nuevo precio de equilibrio
y este va a ser exactamente 10 dólares
mayor que el anterior precio si el
anterior era 75 ó 76 el nuevo estará en
85 u 86
así que esta distancia de acá es 10
pensemos en algunas cosas veamos la
ganancia total que obtendrá el gobierno
con este impuesto
la ganancia será de estos 10 dólares
multiplicado por las 3 mil dosis al año
por lo que obtendrán 30 mil dólares por
año ahora veamos de qué excedente salió
esta cantidad esto de acá es la ganancia
del impuesto los productores van a tener
exactamente el mismo excedente que
tenían antes pero toda esta ganancia del
impuesto va a venir del excedente del
consumidor otra cosa interesante a notar
aquí es que debido a que tenemos esta
curva de demanda perfectamente en
elástica el elevar el precio no
disminuyó la cantidad demandada por lo
tanto no tenemos una pérdida de peso
muerto aquí tenemos exactamente la misma
cantidad a producir así que tenemos una
transferencia de excedentes por parte de
los diabéticos hacia algo
en esa situación pero no se tiene una
pérdida de excedente como tal no hay un
área perdida que pudiéramos señalar en
la intersección entre la curva de
demanda y la curva de la oferta otra
forma de verlo es que la cantidad
demandada no disminuye debido al aumento
de precio